bienvenidos a este programa especial de
france 24 en español desde argentina
hablaremos de la situación económica en
que se encuentra el país tras el duro
golpe asestado por la pandemia de coin
19 que llegó cuando la nación ya llevaba
dos años de recesión las cifras son
contundentes según los últimos datos
oficiales más del 40 por ciento de los
argentinos son pobres y más del 10 por
ciento indigentes y la tasa de desempleo
que está apenas por debajo del 10%
enmascara mucho empleo informal
cuentapropista y de bajos ingresos los
salarios de los empleados y los ingresos
de los pequeños trabajadores
independientes han perdido poder de
compra en una economía con persistente
alta inflación no obstante poco a poco
aparecen datos alentadores hay un
incremento en la actividad económica y
en el uso de la capacidad instalada de
la industria y se espera que la economía
de 2021 se recupere por encima de lo que
cayó en 2020 en calles comerciales como
ésta locales que estaban vacíos
comenzaron a ocuparse y ahí ejemplos
claros de quienes encontraron
oportunidades en medio
en el siguiente reportaje comenzamos con
una de esas historias para preguntarnos
es suficiente
ahora estoy rellenando
con arroz a maní
césar mil son y sus socios se mudaron a
este local tras comenzar su
emprendimiento en un garaje en plena
pandemia como los astronómicos nos
quedamos sin trabajo
porque cambio los trabajos pues no
queríamos trabajar de la manera que nos
proponían los globales y pasamos a
querer hacer nuestra propia propuesta
ellos tuvieron respaldo consiguieron
financiación de todos modos si se
reconoce que fue un riesgo emprender en
un momento de incertidumbre económica es
jugado sí que es un poco jugado era
nuestro tiempo nosotros en un principio
probamos con nuestro tiempo funcionó y
ahí empezamos a buscar un poquito más de
personal y gente que nos vaya
acompañando en este proceso si bien el
caso de césar y su socia es una muestra
de que existe algo de crecimiento en la
economía argentina la situación está
lejos de haberse estabilizado como
señala el consultor ricardo delgado la
argentina este año va a haber recuperado
y algo por encima la caída de del año
2020 que ha sido desde casi el 10 por
ciento del producto pero la preocupación
que sigue hacia adelante tiene que ver
básicamente con bajar los niveles de
inflación si la economía argentina no
logra reducir en los aumentos de precios
base difícil que puedes recuperar
actividad económica y consumo una
actividad que se vio especialmente
golpeada por la pandemia algo que vivió
en cambio propia sandra blanco por la
crisis y tras años de trabajo ya no pudo
alquilar más este local raro porque me
costó 16 años armarlo mantenerlo
en una semana lo tuve que desarmar eso
fue como raro verlo vacía hoy atiende a
sus clientes de servicios de estética
aquí el mismo lugar en el que vive este
pequeño departamento alquilado y este
año ya se me fue muy difícil muy difícil
porque bueno las cosas aumentaban la
gente venía a menos
los alquileres subían
y bueno todo subía además de cerrar el
local sandra tuvo que ajustar las
compras esto como que estaba lleno y
ahora no es como que compro dentro de
todo como para el día imagínate que
estás ir a las compras de dos años que
había una oferta o sea este año a sidra
no compro y ella no tiene buenas
perspectivas para el futuro inmediato
por ejemplo abrir otro local lo veo hoy
imposible
hoy lo veo imposible
lo que le ocurre a sandra que siente que
dejó de ser de clase media se replica en
otros sectores de la sociedad una
sociedad profundamente afectada por la
inflación así la lenta recuperación
económica no termina de traducirse en
una distribución equitativa de ingresos
todo en un contexto en el que el
gobierno se encuentra renegociando una
enorme deuda con el fondo monetario
internacional y en el que otra vez
comenzaron a subir los casos de kobe 19
y todavía no se sabe cuál será el
impacto de la variante omicron y llegará
a 2022 con nuevas restricciones que
comprometan la recuperación y profundice
en la crisis argentina con buenos
niveles de vacunación logrará evitar una
nueva ola y alcanzar una cierta
estabilidad y más allá de la pandemia
que ocurrirá con el fondo monetario
internacional esas son las grandes
preguntas que los argentinos están
haciendo y que el discurrir del nuevo
año irá respondiendo
muchas gracias por acompañarnos en esta
edición especial desde argentina los
invito ahora a seguir con la
programación de france 24 en español